ja wir kommen zu aktuellen sie zu heute
geht es in das digitale höse das ist ein
spannendes thema ich habe in diesem
seminar auch noch ein anderes thema
angeboten nämlich über gut und böse
allgemein da nach oben rechts und links
zur playlist hinein aber wir müssen uns
angesichts der digitalisierung fragen ob
es neue formen des bösen gibt überhaupt
was das böse ist das unmoralische wie
auch immer ich habe ein paar leitfragen
dazu vorbereitet die dieses buch hier
betreten von luciano florida was heute
im zentrum stehen soll die sx auf
information wir haben eine anderen 17
mal der informations begriff auch
kritisch diskutiert auch da mach ich
oben rechts den link rein ich bin der
meinung in formation trägt nicht in
allen hinsichten zur bestimmung des
wenigen was jetzt durch die
digitalisierung neu entsteht ich glaube
brauchen auch andere begriffe wird wird
die realität von einem aber jedenfalls
ist das ein spannender ansatz dann ist
es ein ansatz der wirklich alle bereiche
des lebens
behandelt und ich zeige ihnen mal hier
kurz
eine kleine übersicht aus seinem buch
das jetzt kapitel 6 aus diesem buch und
da sehen wir hier in der einleitung
sagte ein objekt orientiert model of
more action will eine objektorientierte
theorie moralischer handlung entwickeln
objekte sind natürlich auch digitale
objekte also nicht mehr nur vom subjekt
aus dem objekt aus das ist sehr sehr
spannend erfragt dann auch hier weiter
unten bord hätten tui will was was ist
mit dem bösen passiert und kapitel 9 mit
dem wir uns heute vor allem befassen
werden ist dem audi fischer über
gewidmet alledem künstlich bösen was
seiner meinung nach eben auch durch die
digitalisierung entsteht hier ein paar
leitfragen habe ich schon gesagt also
die bestimmte flüge gibt ist die erste
frage das böse
bestimmt floridas otti fischer ebay im
speziellen das künstliche böse warum
benötigen wir nach florida einen neuen
begriff des bösen angesichts der
digitalisierung
inwiefern können wir aktivitäten
künstlicher intelligenz als böse
charakterisieren
inwiefern das jetzt eine weiterführende
frage die mir noch eingefallen ist die
auch im anschluss diskutieren werden
inwiefern können wir aktionen im darknet
als böse bezeichnet und zum schluss und
das knüpft anderen die letzte sitzung wo
wir es mit computerspielen zu tun hatten
dann mache ich auch oben rechts im bild
noch mal rein die frage ganz konkrete
liefern können wir aktionen im
computerspielen als böse bezeichnet und
das nicht sehr spannende frage weil wir
gesehen haben computer spielen ja nicht
mehr direkt wirklichkeit bedeutet das
hat was mit dem wirklichkeit spiel zu
tun insofern muss auch die ethische
bewertung hier etwas reflektierter
geschehen jetzt zum digitalen
künstlichen bösen jetzt bringt florida
in seinem buch erst einmal allgemein
eine bestimmung des bösen sagt sunrise
in den terms of die informationen morgen
an sich sein informations modell was
allem zugrunde liegt messages auch cross
ist perfekt der passion pit
positiv wie negativ
positiv messages respekt ein happy
halloween negativ messages donath
respect the actual damage keys will be
evil actions kann gerüstet ist es ab
glas auf negativ messages dass der ton
hat mir gefehlt um respekt pottkamp
damage geht also hier sieht man wieder
es geht um handlungen und die sind für
ihn
nachrichten genauer gesagt informationen
als informationen negativ informationen
die das wohlergehen oder wohlbefinden
einer gewissen person die diese
nachricht rezipiert gefährden was
natürlich jetzt sehr allgemein kann man
sich fragen was ist denn jetzt eine
negative nachricht
was ist das ja man könnte sich zum
beispiel überlegen eine spam-mail das
ist eine negative nachricht weil die das
wohlergehen der person gefährdet in
einer weise wenn sie nämlich drauf
reinfällt also dann das camp e-mails sie
können das beliebig fortsetzen betrugs e
mails dann wird die person am ende sehr
viel schaden auch finanziell und
vielleicht auch psychisch
also es geht schon dank dass nachrichten
informationen selbst eine form erhalten
die böse genannt werden kann weil in
diesen nachrichten dinge vorgegeben
werden die so nicht stimmen das ist
natürlich jetzt nicht spezifisch neues
an der digitalisierung sie können ja
auch einen brief bekommen in ihr
postfach der wirkliches reales
physisches postfach dem sie reingelegt
werden so einfach ist es also nicht
jetzt definierte eine böse handlung one
or more negativ messages in michele
mitbringst erbaut und transformation of
states that can damage welding sie
william necessarily
olivier patience angst endlich message
nachrichten negative nachrichten die von
einer person oder was auch immer
initiiert werden
die eben von pp eine
einschränkung seines wohlbefindens
bewirken können eine patience anfang lee
message ja was ist denn jetzt eine
friendly match
wahrscheinlich auch eine persönliche die
wirklich adressiert ist viele der
neueren spam oder spam e mails sind gar
nicht wirklich persönlich adressiert
dabei die eben gesperrt werden die gehen
an millionen von nutzerinnen nutzern und
geben vor sie sagen persönlich
adressiert dabei sind es rund mails
haben man könnte sagen eine positive
message schwere eine die sich
ehrlicherweise wirklich auch persönlich
an diese person beendet und nicht nur
vorgibt dies zu tun es hat also sehr
viel mit scheint tun mit simulation
frequently special
pa confronted bei visual and the world
hat neue disziplin
petzschner meinte
das natürliche böse ist zb
naturkatastrophen
krankheiten dass das marum physikum so
nennt man das eine tradition oder
das mal um moral das sind unmoralischen
handlungen ja und jetzt sagte es gibt da
noch ein drittes in der geschichte der
philosophie gibt's auch noch eintritt
ist nämlich das mal um metaphysik um das
metaphysische stößen bei leibnitz war ja
auch oben rechten linken zu diesem
seminar leibnitz theorie des bösen er
sagt jetzt aber es gibt noch eine dritte
form und das ist dass pauli fischer über
und jetzt bringt er beispiel männer sind
da ist begrüßt die ambiance was delayed
beide traffic der computer based monitor
reboots in dem müll auf server software
ist noch voll kompatibel mit allen
bürgern also news with a result of the
passion ist increased the spirit of
spirit die gesamten scotty sowie malte
platz bot kein softie bettlaken täglich
in den sinn simply admissions oft kommt
also diese formen des bösen die durch
die neue technologie entstehen wie etwa
der neustart eines computers sie kennen
das alle der startet zu unmöglichen
zeitpunkten einfach neu bereits ein
update gibt und wird alle programme und
anschließend es geben daten unter
umständen verloren der kann dazu führen
dass wäre bei einer
operation dass da eine person zu schaden
kommt und jetzt kann man nach wie die
nicht mehr treffen sagen das war einfach
pech bett lag oder ein technisches
problem
das wird dieses phänomen nicht mehr
gerecht das ist so seine these netto
agent und jetzt geht es um die frage was
ist ein auge fisher england künstlicher
agenten künstliche akteur und zwar ein
happy end ist ein agent des antelope
basin den namen konstitution of reality
in kunstvollen street
das independent human beings
international airport fischer agent ist
unser testauto logical basin der jungen
constructed realität die pants and least
for jetzt die mission ab um junge
pythons inter menschen nato said it will
take that as some kind of control of
states and action senses dezember um and
response to changes djokovic
interessierte
person gold with the direct intervention
auf paare agence
ihr ziehen wir hier es gibt verschiedene
türen es gibt natürliche akteuren
von der intervention von anderen
menschen das sind zb tiere könnte man
sich vorstellen oder eben auch menschen
die funktioniert sich nur aus sich
selbst heraus an künstlicher mensch der
ein künstlicher agent muss man sagen man
könnte es ja kein roboter erinnert
fühlen er hat seine unter logischen
basis in einer von menschen erzeugen
realität der technologie und ist
abhängig zumindest
was seine entstehung anbelangt durch
menschliche intervention der muss ja
hergestellt werden von menschen kann
auch von anderen robotern hergestellt
werden aber die müssen irgendwann können
sich unendlich kette vorstellt von
menschen erzeugt worden sein und ein
autonomes akteur der hat irgendwie
kontrolle über seine aktion wird es die
frage aber lange darüber diskutiert nach
oben rechts noch einen link zu der
sitzung mit dem buch von kathrin ist
können wir roboter überhaupt hals
autoren bezeichnen er spricht davon dass
das geht wenn die direkte intervention
von anderen aktueller nicht vor wenn ein
gewisses selbstkontrolle
festzustellen und jetzt bringt er hier
eine interessante übersicht taxonomie
agence als er unterscheidet zwischen der
art dem modus des agenten der frage ob
sie natürlich sind oder künstlich und
jetzt sagt er hier die abkürzung ein ns
agent or persons
angel gordon extra stick
natürlich und autonome aktien das heißt
dessen entstehung nicht durch andere
menschen oder personen
beeinflusst wurde das ist so diese these
hier dann gibt es den nhl und dieser
natürlichen der ist natürlich und
autohupen pia galerie gibt es auch den
nhl darunter ist ein national und hätte
rolle des agent
jeff law the squaire kationen es gibt
auch nach seiner these natürliche
akteure also natürliche phänomene die
etwas
eine handlung vollzieht frage zeigen die
aber wiederum sind hier ist das beispiel
eines erdbebens na das ist setzt sich
natürlich selbst ziel und zweck zunahme
auch nicht mehr man kann mir gewisse
strukturen erkennen die mir einheitliche
form aufweisen niemandem weitesten sind
als handlung bezahlen könnte es ging auf
die rechte seite auf die seite des
künstlichen
die fischerin ottos agent zum beispiel
ein web bot expert system software aires
roboter diesen also künstlich und
autonom das ist die frage die wir uns
gestellt hatten und ein web bot ist für
ihn etwas was durchaus böse im sinne des
ordens bezeichne diese airways die
können auto fischer boel hervorbringen
und runter gibt es noch eine
frische und head of spain das ist
traffic inflation und politischen
jetzt ist die frage wie
sieht es aus mit dem reboot
des computers nein die hatte irgendwas
mit dem traffic auch zu tun mit einer
verstopfung aber man kann auch sagen ein
expertensystem ist ja auch ein computer
heran die waren nur ein programm also
dass wir die frage ob inszeniert dieses
artikels einfach ein reboot eines
computers bei der operation böse zu
bezeichnen wäre oder vielleicht eher ein
web bot ein virus der die software in
der krankenhaus in dem moment zerstört
wo gerade ein patient behandelt das wäre
sicherlich ein ganz klarer fall das
künstlich bis die hammers also die
aficionados agence hier
künstlich und autonom dies sind der
kandidat für das archiv
jetzt gehen wir weiter und befassen uns
noch mit dem dark dass damit ist auch
ein phänomen was man als das digitale
böse bezeichnen könnte es gibt ja buch
von otto stettler das im jahr 2017
erschienen und das hat den titel da
nicht die schattenwelt des internets
finde es ist aber sehr gute sind lauter
901 und
wir was hier mit dem dunklen der dunklen
seite des internets zu tun die
beschreibung des buches lautet
folgendermaßen im atemberaubenden tempo
entstehen verborgen bereichen des
internets blühende schwarzmärkte
verwarfen drogen medikamente falsche
pässe kreditkarten oder hacker die erste
diese anonymen online shops sind
kundenfreundlich und
nutzerorientiert bezahlt wird mit
bitcoins oder anderen crypto währungen
crypto währung ist das nächste thema
crypto ist ja auch verborgen creditors
eine krypta sie kennt dieses wort
kryptisch das bedeutet verborgen also
damit ist die verborgene seite die
schattenseite des internets und hier
stellt sich jetzt die frage wie für
diese seite böse zu bezeichnen ist hier
gibt es noch eine grafik von g data die
ich sehr übersichtlich findet es da gibt
sie sehen es gibt es internet
schließlich unterscheiden das klima das
die obere hälfte dieses kreises
und des
dark age diese ist nicht klar jetzt
sozusagen
und hier sehen sie es gibt was die obere
spitze des eisberges ist nur der
geringste teil des internets den wir
sehen denn wir
zugänglich haben auf denen die zugreifen
können mit unseren brausen das ist nicht
der größte teil
und es gibt auch noch das deep web das
sind nicht indexierte seiten die finden
sie gar nicht durch suchmaschinen dann
müssen sie irgendwie anders drauf kommen
und illegale bereiche muss man faire
halber sagen die gibt es auch im clip
gibt es da natürlich auch nämlich wenn
sich zb bei
movies streamen von streaming plattform
die nicht legal sind
das ist ganz klar illegal wenn sie sich
neuen programme herunterladen von
irgendwelchen servern wenn das auch
nicht legaler können sie können sie per
suchmaschine finden sogar diese diese
software also das ist vielleicht wichtig
zu betonen das ganze internet enthält
illegale bereiche
spannend wirds aber eben vor allem in
der unteren hälfte dass das netz vor
allem inter sie also der hier sehen sie
das ist dieses schwarze bereich der ist
gar nicht mehr grau oder so oder weiß
sondern da kommen sie wirklich nur ein
mit einladung oder passwort oder mit
einem tor pause das mit einem speziellen
software hier ist alles auch
verschlüsselt und einfach hochgradig
privat und er ist man ja nicht irgendwie
verboten es ist einfach nur hochgradig
geschützt und hochgradig geschützter
raum und ein hochgradig abgekapselte
raum das ist vielleicht ganz wichtig und
jetzt müssen wir uns fragen was hat
damit moralphilosophen auf sich wenn wir
das internet als einen virtuellen
öffentlichen handlungsraum verstehen das
haben wir so getan unserem seminar dann
erscheint das darf nicht als ein
abgekapseltes schatten raum also dass
damit entzieht sich dieser struktur der
öffentlichkeit des internets und kapselt
sich ab jetzt kann man sich die frage
stellen inwiefern eine abkapselung eines
virtuellen handlungsraum
inwiefern der selbst einen moralischen
raum also wie für alle tendenzen die
gegen die tendenz das internet sind
nämlich sich zu vernetzen öffentlich zu
werden ob die nicht selbst in einer
gewissen form unmoralisch gelangt werden
können es sind alle handlungen die im
damit vollzogen werden als solche kann
man sich fragen bereits unmoralisch weil
sie in sofern sie sich überhaupt in
diesem darknet vollziehen sind sie als
solche schon böse oder unmoralisch ist
die frage man kann jetzt sagen
eine handlung im virtuellen raum ist
dadurch unmoralisch dass sie den
virtuellen handlungsraum verkleinern ist
dass sie den verkleinert man könnte
jetzt argumentieren damit tragen die
handlung dazu bei den virtuellen
handlungsrahmen zu verkleinern und das
wäre eine möglichkeit das digitale böse
zu bestimmen ohne abhängig von schadens
erwägen wies luciano florida getan
einfach als verkleinerung des virtuellen
handwerks und
computerspiele inwiefern ist das
simulierte töten simulierter personen
computerspiel unmoralisch zu nennen wenn
dabei doch niemand wirklich zu schaden
kommt das war die riesen debatte was
passiert wenn wir eine simulierte person
simuliert töten
töten und simulators sozusagen ja da
kommt jemand zu schaden das sieht
natürlich aus als ob da jemand zu
schaden käme da wird viel simuliert aber
am ende ist die welt genau dieselbe die
physische welt zumindest da ist nichts
passiert keine person hat objektiv
wirklich leid erfahren nur simulierte
slide nämlich eine simulierte person man
kann sich jetzt fragen wir haben das
ausführlich getan kommt vielleicht die
person am ende wenigstens zu schaden die
computer spielt
auch wenn sie gar nicht an sich selbst
den schaden simuliert sondern einer
anderen simulierten person dass die
frage inwiefern können wir mit blick auf
computerspielen vom fiktiven oder
simulant tiefen bösen sprechenden wirkt
geben gegensatz zum wirklichen zunächst
werden die frage stellt sich ja auch
schon dann wenn wir es mit gewalt
verherrlichende literatur zu tun haben
wo in fiktiver weise grausame details
explizit besprochen werden zum beispiel
wie eine person getötet wird hier ist
der unterschied zum computerspiel wieder
sagen dass wir bei einer fiktiven
erzählung selbst nicht in die handlung
eingreifen die handlung wird uns
präsentiert wir müssen sie vor unserem
geistigen auge durch fantasie
entstehen lassen aufbauen geistige
bilder erzeugen aber wir selbst
bestimmen die handlung dadurch nicht
sondern wir rekapitulieren sie nur wir
visualisieren
vergegenwärtigen
anders ist beim computerspiel da greifen
wir selbst einen die handlung da können
wir dann entscheiden gegebenfalls wie
wird diese person töten wollen das
können wir im roman nicht es gibt man
ein fortsetzungsroman wo man dann
verschiedene optionen auswählen kann und
dann je nach dem auf der seite weiter
lesen kann auf der das ist der versuch
interaktivität reinzubringen den
erzählfluss aber es doch was ganz
anderes weil die reibungslose ich kai
timm computerspiel einfach viel größer
ist der handlungsspielraum ist ein
wirklicher spielraum und nicht nur eine
alternative tät von teilfunktionen ich
denke ich dass man das direkt
vergleichen kann
ja worin könnte dann das virtuelle böse
bestehen computerspiele sind ja
eigentlich nur simulationen aber sie
werden manchmal zu virtuellen realitäten
haben wir gesagt ja und das wird mich
eben noch mal zu dieser these dass
virtuelle böse verzieht sich im
virtuellen raum den es verkleinert und
fängt zum beispiel können hier auch
falschinformation
anonyme falsche informationen dazu
beitragen
die eben dann diesen informationsraum
verkleinern weil sie eben falsch sind
und täuschung einbringen und auch im
netz verbleiben und eben nicht mehr als
herauszukriegen sind und zur
desorientierung führen kann also alles
was im virtuellen handlungsraum
desorientiert was schein produzieren das
könnte man als das virtuelle böse
bezeichnet
jetzt wollen wir uns abschließend auch
mit der frage befassen inwiefern
virtuelle das böse auch mit blick auf
künstliche intelligenz zu denken ist
also kann künstliche intelligenz als
solche böse sein dass die frage florida
hat ja von den ace gesprochen autonome
sorry fischer agence und für ihn würden
also roboter ki auch unter mögliche
größe fälle fallen jetzt muss man aber
sich fragen wie verhalten sich
programmieren nutzerinnen ki zueinander
das ist ja ein komplexes verhältnis
werden das auch schon mal besprochen
hand des autonomen fahren
hier wird ganz schwierig verantwortung
zuzuschreiben ich selbst bin skeptisch
die verantwortung der künstlich
intelligent selbst zuzuschreiben wie es
flori die tut weil das würde bedeuten ki
zu personifizieren
dabei hängt sie von ihrer ursprünglichen
ausrichtung immer von den programmierern
und der nutzerinnen und nutzer ab das
heißt sie bezieht ihre zwecke
ursprünglich immer von einer anderen
instanz und darin ist die mahnung dann
die verantwortung zu sehen aber man kann
keinen dass wenn ich jetzt das
spannendere aufweisen verwenden die
durchaus sehr
böse sein können nämlich zum beispiel
für das firma dass die fei das betrifft
wieder die täuschung durch
digitalisierung die simulation die
pflege ist eine nahezu perfekte
simulation einer zum beispiel einer
person kürzlich gab es die debatte ob
der klitschko in einem rahmen eines die
fakes simuliert wurde und man so
verschiedene politiker reingelegt hat
das ist wohl noch nicht ganz klar aber
so kann man das tun also man kann
personen worte in den mund legen die
sich selbst nie sagen würden und noch
nie gesagt haben weil man sie so perfekt
die wir von künstliche intelligenz
natürlich künstlichen neuronalen netzen
simulieren kann und hier stellt sich
glaube ich vor allem jetzt im blick auf
das böse die frage wann werden wir
wirklichkeit von simulationen nicht mehr
unterscheiden können und was passiert
dann ich glaube das ist die
entscheidende frage die verwechslung von
simulationen mit wirklichkeit das ist
letztendlich eine moralische frage ob
die grenze noch besteht wenn sie
verwischt wird dann bekommen wir große
moralische probleme und die
digitalisierung trägt eben auch dazu bei
diese grenze zu verwischen zum beispiel
mit jedem fall künstlicher intelligenz
mehr trägt alle die verantwortung für
die aktionen von kdg selbst das ist die
entscheidende frage da gibt es viel
debatten drum ich persönlich bin wie
gesagt skeptisch dass auf die ki selbst
abzugrenzen
ja als ihm am ende der heutigen sitzung
ich bin noch einen ganz kurzen ausblick
geben auf die nächste sitzung in der
nächsten woche da wollen wir das thema
das digitale gute
ins zentrum stellen jetzt haben wir ja
mit dem digitalen bösen zu tun gehabt
jetzt kann man sich genauso fragen was
ist dann das digitale gute
zb könnte man sagen dass digitale gute
führt geradezu eine erweiterung des
virtuellen handlungsrahmens und nicht zu
einer verengung oder einer verkleinerung
wie es das tag zum beispiel tut oder wie
es die täuschungen dass die fähigsten
meine these wird sein dass das gute
dass das gute dadurch zustande kommt
dass es unsere virtuelle realität
vergrößern das was virtuelle realität
prinzipiell vergrößert ist ist
prinzipiell erst mal gut zu nennen dass
wir meine these natürlich auch dann wenn
wir ihm der virtuellen realität böses
tun können wie kann natürlich auch das
virtuelle böse vollziehen das ist ganz
richtig dennoch glaube ich dass
virtuelle realität intrinsisch die
tendenzen guten hat weil sie eben gerade
nicht schein bedeutet zur neue
möglichkeiten eröffnet und dadurch
unsere freiheit vergrößern das war es
für die heutige sitzung jetzt gehen wir
gleich und bleibe diskussion vielen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit